it is inauguration day i'm sorry to say
and i'm sorry for a number of reasons
not the least of which is
certainly now we're going to see a lot
of violence
from those insurrectionist terroristic
republicans who just a few weeks ago
committed
an unprecedented shocking historic coup
d'etat
type act of violence at the capitol i i
can only imagine that
as a matter of unprecedented historic
unprecedented violence
we're going to see that kind of awful
terrible stuff today at the inauguration
not everyone gathered here in washington
today came to celebrate president
trump's inauguration
protesters lined part of the parade
route and in some parts of the capitol
there were confrontations with police
the anger reaching a boiling point in
the nation's capital after president
trump took the oath of office
police in riot gear facing off against
the protesters
just six blocks from the inaugural
parade
unleashing pepper spray concussion
grenades
all to disperse the crowd burning cars
and smashed windows a small group of
protesters dressed in black
their faces covered armed with hammers
and bricks
facing off with thousands of officers on
site many in riot gear
confronting them with flashbang grenades
and pepper spray
before the swearing-in ceremony even
began protesters tried to block
checkpoint entrances during president
trump's speech
several demonstrators were escorted out
of the area
several officers injured during the
protest today and more than a hundred
people
arrested more than a hundred people
arrested for things like setting cars on
fire setting
stores on fire assaulting countless
people
that was the last one that wasn't this
one that's so weird that was at the
inauguration of president trump
and we're not talking about that today
because no one cares about political
violence
or lawlessness or any other insanity
when it comes from the left
because that's just the status quo and
if joe biden's inauguration
means anything it means a return
to normalcy a return to decadent
degraded
normalcy i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from last week
was from joe mann who was referring to
the daily wire movie which just came out
he said
without even watching you already know
that run hide fight is good
since the audience gave it a 98 and the
leftist critics gave it a 17 on rotten
tomatoes that is true that is one of the
keys to it
uh the left uh sort of critical
hollywood establishment
is furious about this movie but the
audience seemed to really like it so
thanks everyone for coming out
hanging out with us i guess that might
have been the last time that we were all
hanging out together
uh because i took a couple of days off
you know
i am genuinely very very sad
about uh president trump's leaving
office you know and
uh there are a number of reasons of this
for this
but i one of it is i really want to be
prepared
you always want to be prepared for the
worst things that can happen and
but luckily i am prepared and that's
because i have a ready-wise ready-wise
makes being prepared simple
and affordable order online and have
nutritious meals shipped
directly to your doorstep readywise
products are proudly made in the usa
each recipe is crafted by a team of
chefs to provide delicious
nutritional meals especially during
critical times
with a 99 satisfaction rate and millions
of products sold
ready wise has quickly become the leader
in emergency preparedness
i got to tell you i used to be one of
these guys i don't need to be prepared
well
it'll be fine i'll be all right then
2020 happened you know
and i i sort of changed my views
this week my listeners can get 10 off at
readywise.com
when entering knolls10 at checkout or by
calling 855
453 2945 ready wise has a 30 day no
questions asked return policy
so there is no risk in taking the
initiative to get you and your family
prepared today
you're not going to want to return it
these guys are top in the business
that is readywise r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e dot
com promo code
to get 10 percent off go head on over
check out rediwas you know much how much
i love them i am genuinely
very very sad that president trump is
leaving office
it's been so fun it has been the most
fun political experience
of my life that i've ever lived through
uh conservatives i think have
accomplished more certainly than we've
accomplished in my life and
probably for many decades before that
so i am genuinely very sad on
inauguration day
however i'm not that sad generally
because the reason i've been out the
past couple days is i just had a kid
i would say thank you to everybody for
sending in
the uh well wishes um my
my son has now already mastered
expressions of
bemused dismay and droll
self-satisfaction i posted some of these
photos over the weekend
uh that means that he now has mastered
the entire
breadth of conservative emotions that's
pretty much it that's pretty much all
you can get to
uh so we're all very excited about that
it is helping to temper
our sadness that president koffe is
leaving office which is a genuinely
sad thing we we can now say we have at
least one
new conservative american future
voter of for good things uh on
on this earth and in this country one
new conservative american
soon to be joined by i'm afraid to say
11 million new overwhelmingly
left-wing americans so you see one thing
i was really happy about
with the birth of my son is that well
there were
obviously many many things i was very
happy about but not the least of which
was
he is not a biden baby you see he was
due on the 18th for a first child it's
it's typical for the kid to come later
than the due date i thought no
biden becomes president on the 20th this
is going to be a biden baby he's going
to miss out on all the fun
but he got in on time so he got in two
days before the biden presidency
and uh we're very excited for that uh
all
all the more reason that i haven't slept
in a few days if i fall asleep at the
desk today
uh that's you know perfectly fine just
have someone come in and poke me
um because we're we're gonna fall asleep
unfortunately not
not today we're going to fall asleep for
the next four years and it's not going
to be because
everything is perfectly fine and
hunky-dory it's because
it's going to go back to the radical
status quo
that we had in effect before trump came
into office
before trump came into office things
were happening
very very quickly i mean just just to
give you a quick example
we went from on the issue of
same-sex marriage whatever your views on
same-sex marriage that's actually not my
point right now
you had one definition more or less of
marriage for all of human history
then with obergefell at the insistence
of obama
you had a fundamental redefinition of
marriage and then
a year after that you had the apparently
fundamental right for men to go use the
women's bathroom
and for men to go and to use the the
girls changing room at the public pool
that's how that's how
quickly this sort of thing can
accelerate when barack obama ran for
president in 2008 he opposed gay
marriage in in
very strong terms hillary clinton too
right they said this was
marriage is a sacred union between a man
and a woman and they have no intent on
over overturning it
then obama in 2012 it wasn't until right
around the second term that he changes
his view on that
within a couple of years you now have
this sort of fundamental right to
transgenderism
and all of these kind of radical sexual
ideologies the acceleration was really
really quick
we went from barack obama saying that it
would be unconstitutional to give out
executive amnesty
just to the dreamers right the dreamers
actually they're now as old as 44 years
old
but at least the image of the dreamers
is that they're supposed to be like six
years old and they're really cute and
you know their parents brought them over
and it's not their fault and we've got
to give them
amnesty we went from barack obama saying
that would be unconstitutional
to it's so
in effect that even donald trump
can't overturn it he tried quartz shut
it down now
we're at the place where joe biden says
we're going to give amnesty to 11
million people
path to citizenship future democratic
voters and that
and that is just a fact by the way i i'm
not i'm hoping
that somehow these voters will become
conservative republicans i hope reagan
is right when he says that
a lot of these voters are republicans
they just don't know it yet but the the
public opinion polls don't really bear
it out it would seem that
that recent immigrants from latin
america
identify with the democratic party
overwhelmingly you're talking about
80 percent plus and which is of course
the reason why democrats are so keen
on on pushing for amnesty that's a
radical policy
right but we don't we don't feel like
it's radical because we're like the
we're like the frog in the hot water we
as things continue to heat up and heat
up and get more radical and more radical
we're just not paying attention to it
and there is the full force of the media
higher education lower education for
that matter big tech
especially now big tech we'll get to
that in a second uh the bureaucracy
everybody is pushing for it and so
ordinary americans who maybe don't have
institutional power
and certainly have zero institutional
power now that trump is leaving they're
gonna look up and say wait a second what
what is happening you're going to
legalize 11 million people
and then you're going to upend the
voting system or you're going to keep
the upended voting system that we had
in 2020. this doesn't this doesn't look
good guys
and there's not going to be very much to
do about it because the entire weight of
the establishment
is behind it the way we know about this
11 million illegal alien policy by the
way
is because it's being reported on by the
mainstream media and
this brings me to one point that i think
people sometimes forget
when we've got a republican
administration and then we have a
democratic administration
we beat up on the media all the time
right we say these reports are unfounded
they're ridiculous it's the fake news
don't believe it
so why should i believe a report from
whether it's the new york times or nbc
or whoever
that says that biden's going to legalize
11 million or that's what's being talked
about
when the media report on a democratic
policy
that is a fundamentally different thing
than when
the media report on a republican policy
and the reason for that is
that the media are the democrats and the
democrats are the media
whereas when it comes to the republicans
they are adversaries
right the republicans hate the media the
media hate the republicans
so the media are always looking to try
to
[Music]
antagonize the republicans and they
don't have particularly good sources
whereas with the democrats they do and
so when something like this is being
leaked
you know it's being leaked by the
administration you know they're floating
it out there to see what the reaction is
and you know they know that they're
going to get good press coverage
so it is going to be more reliable
you're actually going to have to change
how you look at the media from where you
have been looking at them for the past
four years and the other
the other evidence of radicalism you
don't even need to look to the new york
times for you don't even need to look to
nbc or washington post because some of
these nominees are already coming up
and they are really really radical and
they're radical on matters of education
and they're radical on matters of public
health certainly public health has
become
the big issue of 2020 and
joe biden has an historic public health
nominee which we'll get to probably get
censored if we even talk about it but
we're going to have to talk about it
anyway and they are radical specifically
on this issue
of immigration and maybe the
the most surprising thing you're going
to see even just in the next few weeks
is not that you can believe the media a
little bit more when they report on
democrat policies
because the media are basically the
press secretaries
one of the most shocking things is that
uh heretofore squishy republicans are
gonna seem to grow a backbone they're
gonna seem to grow a spine
even guys like i can't believe i'm
saying this
guys like mitt romney are about to seem
like strong tough conservatives who want
to defend the country and don't want
amnesty
not only are you going to see it you're
already
seeing it a huge
huge surprise you know
i'm often surprised when i go to the
auto parts store and they charge me a
lot of money and they ask me a lot of
questions about things i don't know
anything about
don't do that you go to rockauto.com
it's much much easier much much better
family-owned business
rockauto.com is so much easier than
walking into a store
and someone demanding quick answers to
questions like for instance
is your odyssey an lx or an ex i don't
know what kind of x my odyssey is why
are you asking me that
then they usually wanna have the part in
the store so they'll go into the back
they'll probably go to rockauto.com
order the part then charge you twice as
much
don't you don't need to do that you can
access rockauto.com
at your desk and in your pocket best of
all prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low
they are the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers why would you want to
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts
the rockauto.com catalog is unique it's
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available
for your vehicle and choose the brands
specifications and prices that you
prefer
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car
or truck these guys are a family-owned
business
and they've been serving these online
customers for about 20 years which as
far as i can tell is like the whole
history of the internet
write in knolls in the how did you hear
about us box so that they know that we
sent you
you know how much i love them go check
out rock auto
mitt romney mitt romney
the most liberal republican in the
senate
certainly in the top three just came out
to grill
the joe biden department of homeland
security nominee
uh he came out because dhs is going to
be dealing with caravans of people that
are coming up
to you know the southern border he's
going to be dealing with a lot of
immigration issues
and mitt wants to know i can't believe
i'm saying this he wants to know
if they're going to turn those
immigrants away or if they're going to
flout the law
what is your intention with regards to
that caravan
that is coming to our border is your
intention to allow them to come into the
country will they be stopped what what's
the what's the plan
senator
we are a nation of immigrants and we are
also a nation of laws and i
intend to apply the law in the execution
of my responsibilities as the secretary
of homeland security
should i have that privilege i
understand that and and what does that
mean
in this in this regard does that mean
that they will be interdicted and
rejected from coming into the country
evaluated one by one what's the what's
the plan senator
uh when people present themselves at our
border we apply
the laws of our nation to determine
whether they qualify for relief
under our humanitarian laws or whether
they don't
um
kind of uncertain there gee you don't
say i'm it
i actually got to tell you i appreciated
this grilling that he gave him the
nominee is
alejandro mayorkas he's obviously going
to give all of these people amnesty
because his boss joe biden
is saying i want to give amnesty to 11
million people and now mitt romney is
coming in you're probably
very confused you're saying why is mitt
the squishiest of the squishes in the
senate
why is he trying to fight against
illegal immigration
a couple of reasons one this is this is
like the top level reason
you know the the most obvious is maybe
mitt is thinking about running for
president again
i i think very few people would expect
him to
win and probably a few people even would
expect him to run but the guy has run
for president on a number of occasions
he got the nomination one time
after the trump era things are going to
change maybe romney thinks there's going
to be a way for him
to recapture the kind of squishy
moderate route or something
so maybe that's it but i think it's
actually deeper than that
i think the reason that romney is doing
this sort of thing
is because there's no longer a
republican president
so rom it's not just this this grilling
here
romney is actually having a moment so
you'll recall
during the reporting from the capitol
hill riot
there was a report out that mitt romney
turned to
ted cruz and said are you happy with
this ted are you happy with what you've
done or something like that
different versions of this going around
the internet is it true or not i have no
idea but this was being reported
in real time and it obviously fits with
romney's character
as a squishy guy who who didn't want
trump to be president wanted by to be
president wanted to move on
but now cnn is reporting cnn manu raju
is reporting
that mitt romney told him that cruz and
hawley should not be punished in any way
for objecting to the electoral
certification on january 6th
so the democrats want want cruz and
hawley to be booted out of the senate
or at least censured for raising
objections to the electoral vote because
of the
irregularities let's call them in the
2020 election
romney just came out and said i don't do
a very good mitt romney but
but he just came and said i think they
raised they raised questions
which are legitimate within the senate
not something i supported
but i think i think they're entitled to
raise those points
i it's a very bad mitt romney impression
it's so if you want to do a mitt romney
it's sort of like you have to do a
reagan
but then make it lamer and i don't i
haven't haven't succeeded at it and
probably never will
the point he's making though is very
good because i agree with that i can't
believe i'm saying i agree with mitt
romney
especially on an issue like this he's
saying of course cruz and hawley had the
right to raise those objections
they are legitimate objections and we're
not going to kick a senator out
for pursuing a legal process excuse me
sir
what has happened to mitt romney what
have you done who are you
imposter and what have you done with
senator romney
on the one hand great i'm glad that he's
having this moment i'm glad he's being
more conservative i'm glad he's going to
grill people it's probably not going to
do very much but
okay wonderful on the other hand
this is frustrating because of course
mitt romney is good now
of course he's saying the right things
now and doing the right things now and
behaving in the right way now
because he's about to be in the minority
and mitt romney
and republicans like mitt romney were
built
in some factory at establishment gop
headquarters
to be in the minority they're meant to
lose with dignity
they're meant to put up a big fight and
put up a big show
but not actually do anything you know
when it would have mattered it would
have mattered under the trump
administration
that's when it would have mattered to
put up a big fight and there are lots of
people
up to and including the president
perhaps could have done more best
president of my lifetime but sure there
were missed opportunities
and some unforced errors and lots of
problems okay fine
where were you where were all of the
real tough sounding conservatives
when it mattered when it could have
mattered
you were all fighting the republican
presidential administration
and now that it's nice and safe and you
don't need to risk anything
and you know that nothing you say is
going to matter then you can mouth off
and say oh good i'm going to be a big
tough guy now and i'm going to
support the conservatives and i yeah i
hate illegal immigration and yeah i
totally support gruesome hawley
okay fine i mean i'll take that over
nothing i take that over romney
completely defecting to the democrats
but
it's weak sauce guys when
when hillary got the nomination and
trump got the nomination in 2016
the conservative uh humorist p.j
o'rourke who i've always really enjoyed
pg overworks writing
he came out and he he endorsed hillary
clinton
and he said i endorse hillary clinton
and all of her
evil works and all of her empty promises
he said she's really really bad but
she's bad within normal boundaries
and it was a it was actually a brilliant
column because it explained what a lot
of people thought they said i hate
hillary
but hillary's normal you know and trump
is not normal
so i i prefer the devil i know to the
devil that i don't
we're going back into normal and mitt
romney mouthing off when it doesn't
matter that's normal
and pretending to care about illegal
immigration for a lot of republicans
when they don't really care and they're
actually
secretly sort of supportive of it that's
normal and
not caring about abortion but like
raising a big ruckus about abortion but
then not being able to do anything about
it that's
normal and the radicalism that we're
about to see at the border and in
education
and in health policy all of that is
actually normal
within the boundaries of our politics
the problem is our politics has gotten
so completely insane
that in 2016 people voted for this guy
named donald trump
who was a complete outsider to the
elective office and national political
scene
but he talked like a normal person and
his views were ordinary views
totally common sense yes secure the
border
yeah defend america put america before
other countries when you're crafting a
national policy
yeah make sure american workers get a
decent get a decent wage
over slave labor in in china
right that that that donald trump would
appeal to ordinary people
this like eccentric new york billionaire
shows you
how crazy the political scene has gotten
but now we're back
to normal and normal is really
really radical we've got
radical nominees we we talked a little
bit last week about this radical
floated nominee for the department of
justice's
civil rights division this is an
enormous after the civil
rights act these sort of civil rights
offices took on enormous power and
influence
the the doj uh civil rights division has
a lot of power in this country
and the person that joe biden is
reportedly going to nominate for
it has written the craziest
kookiest most radical racist sort of
things
some of which have come back from her
days at harvard she had these theories
that melanin is what gives people mental
physical
and spiritual power and it's why black
people are mentally spiritually and
physically superior
to white people and white people part of
the way the brain functions involves
melanin and that's why
white people are dumb or something and
black people are really smart
all this kind of racialist nonsense that
you'd seen out of the radical left
in the 70s and 80s i'm thinking of wacky
professors like leonard jeffries
who talks about how black people are the
sun people and white people are the ice
people i'm thinking of guys today like
nick cannon you remember the actor nick
cannon
got in trouble because he said melanin
is what gives people their power
and white people are like savages well
the
the biden nominee or reported nominee
for this very powerful post at the doj
civil rights
held these theories at one time and may
well hold those theories today
that's completely insane right but it's
insane within normal boundaries
because of how wacky our boundaries have
gotten and it's not just at the doj
it's also at the education department
it's also at health and human services
which is the
perhaps wackiest one of all before we
get to that last thursday was a very
big day for the daily wire we made our
entrance into
entertainment content with our first
feature film run hide
fight a run hot fight it was really
terrific i got to screen the movie when
we were considering acquiring it
i thought wow man this is pretty cool
what a great way to open up
our our entertainment portion of the
daily wire we'll have a new movie
right in the new year this was a movie
that did well at venice film festival
but it wasn't totally politically
correct it's not a conservative
propaganda movie by any means it just
has conservative values in it
it was it broke a few politically
correct rules
and so it couldn't get distribution we
thought all right we'll distribute it if
you missed it head on over to daily wire
where you can stream it on demand from
our website mobile or streaming apps on
apple tv and roku
if you are not a member yet what are you
doing use promo code rhf
for those of you who are a little slow
this morning because maybe you haven't
slept in a few days like me
that is that stands for run hide fight
you will get 25
off that is rhf for 25
off head on over to dailywire.com we'll
be right back with a lot more
so joe biden's reported nominee for this
very important post in the doj holds a
ton of extremely
racist ugly views
similar views being held apparently by
joe biden's
choice for deputy education secretary
so joe biden announced that he wanted to
pick uh the san diego unified school
district superintendent cindy martin
for deputy secretary of education
deputy secretary of education what what
does the education department even do
i guess not all they don't they're not
empowered to do all that much
by the law or you know this obviously
doesn't appear anywhere in the
constitution
but they do have quite a lot of power to
craft the direction of curriculum in the
united
things like dear st letters
basically strong recommendations from
the federal government
that you know if you want to keep
getting your money if you want to keep
getting all these goodies from the
federal government you have to do what
we want you to do
on various sort of social engineering
policies
the famous dear colleague letter from
the obama administration had to do with
transgender ideology well here this
person who biden wants for deputy
education secretary
very racist views she's a white lady but
she holds these very
sort of uh what do you call it uh
i guess black racialist views the same
kinds of things
that we have just been talking about so
she believes that schools quote
spirit murder black children and what
that white teachers should
should undergo quote anti-racist therapy
anti-racist therapy so you've got now
the announced biden pick
for deputy education secretary calling
for
the reprogramming only of
white teachers who are not
anti-racist enough meaning they they
could be not racist but that's not
enough you've got to be anti-racist
meaning you've got to be racist
[Music]
the teachers are are not focused enough
on how terrible the scourge of white
supremacy is
and how schools quote spirit murder
black children whatever that means
and so they've got to go to re-education
camps
that's not even just being reported that
has been announced
moving over to the department of health
and human services
i've got to be very very careful with
this one because i think we could all be
censored for this
and there are major calls right now for
conservatives to be censored so i'm just
going to present the facts
okay and you tell me if something seems
a little strange
joe biden has selected the pennsylvania
health secretary
dr rachel levine to be
assistant secretary of health and human
services
dr rachel levine that was not his
given name when he was born dr rachel
levine
is a man who thinks that he's a woman
he's being nominated to be the assistant
secretary of health
and human services
a man who is
under the impression that he is a woman
in some deep metaphysical way
that his true identity as a woman even
though all of the characteristics that
he has
are man manly masculine
uh he is now to be the assistant
secretary of health and human services
does that seem a little strange to you
that seems a little strange to me i'm
i don't i don't want to step out of line
i don't want to
uh seems a little strange doesn't it
but it doesn't but it doesn't it only
seems strange
to people with even a modicum of common
sense left
because we are
back into the normal scope of this
liberal political regime
and the normal kinds of politics that we
see here
that's not normal compared to objective
standards that's not normal compared to
historical
norms you know moving back
decades and decades but it is normal
today
and what is also about to be normal i
mean i'm joking a little bit as i'm
tiptoeing around this issue gosh what's
strange about this that a man in a dress
who believes himself to be a woman is
the assistant health secretary
i'm sort of joking as i tiptoe around it
but there's a lot of truth to it which
is that
we are now at a place where if you come
out and say a man is not a woman
and a woman is not a man and a man can't
magically become a woman by wishing it
so and putting a dress on
you will face professional consequences
for it you will face
social consequences for it you can
currently be kicked off of social media
if you do it in a specific way which i
hope my elaborate choreography here
has allowed me to walk around
but you you cannot say that you you feel
as though
you're the last sane person on earth
when you scream into the wind and say
a man is not a woman and a woman is not
a man and there's actually such a thing
as sexual difference
but that that's over
because now we're headed back into the
biden administration which is
it's the same thing as the obama
administration which is just kind of the
same thing as the establishment
left by the way what you're going to
hear specifically with regard to rachel
levine's appointment
you're going to hear that oh no this has
nothing to do
with him being a transgender person this
is just because he's so
qualified and he's just the best pick
for the job
i i don't think that that is very likely
to be true here's why
there is a uh quote from robin gonzalez
of the victory institute
which i suppose is an lgbtq sort of
lobby
he says quote i think there is a value
in giving visibility to doctors
like dr levine who are kind of unique in
their field
not just because of their demographics
and who they are but also because of
their expertise
we also know that when people know lgbtq
people it makes them more open to
supporting our equality
so he he made three arguments here he
made three he gave
three reasons as to why rachel levine
should get this job
it's good to give visibility to doctors
like dr levine
visibility what does that mean means uh
because
he's a man who thinks he's a woman not
just because of their demographics but
also because of their expertise
okay so he's saying it's not just
because he's
transgender it's because he is really
expert at something what we don't know
he doesn't specify
how that expertise is completely unique
and and has nothing to do with
the gender thing but he's so much more
expert than anyone else in the field
he doesn't explain that and then the
third one is it's good when people see
lgbtq
people and here you see the lgbtq is
when you lump in everybody
so a man who comes out and says hey i'm
a guy i'm
attracted to other men that is now
supposed to be considered
part and parcel of the same thing as a
man who says i am a woman
right they're obviously not the same
thing and they actually contradict one
another
but one is a statement of sexual desire
which
anybody can understand and say yeah we
people have sexual desires
you're not pretending that biology and
reality is different than it is you're
just saying
i'm a man i have this sort of unusual
sexual desire but you know a bunch of
other people have it too and that's the
way it is
completely different than a man saying
hi
uh because uh you might be confused
looking at me in all my physical traits
i want you to know
objective reality is not true you
shouldn't believe your lying eyes i who
am a man actually am a woman
totally different things and of course
we've talked about this on this show
before
but if you're if you're going to
promote lgbtq altogether
you're going to run into a problem which
is that the kind of modern
concept of homosexuality is based on
this idea that there are men
and there are women and homosexuals are
men who are attracted to other men and
women who are attracted to other women
and you're you know it goes along with
mottos like we're born this way you know
and
you can't change who you are and sexual
orientation is not changeable
okay fine totally got it you cannot then
also say that there is no such thing as
sex and that all of these things
are changeable and not only is sexual
desire changeable but
but my sex itself is changeable so i can
become a man i can be a man of
pretend that i'm a woman and then really
become a woman
can't have all of those things at once
but you can these days you can i
actually
i actually explain how this uh
this ideology has arisen in my
upcoming book i've never plugged a book
on this show that had any words in it
but i can do this now because in
addition to this kind of crazy 48 hours
i've had
with my wife going to labor and then the
kid coming and it was a very long labor
and so we were at the hospital all the
time
by an act of either cosmic poetry or
cosmic sadism
my baby and my book were both due on the
same day i had to get this manuscript
into the publisher and it's got a lot of
words and it turns out it's harder to
write books with words
but the book is available for pre-order
now it's called speechless
controlling words controlling minds and
it's a history of political correctness
which i think has been completely
misunderstood for decades and
it's why we've completely lost and it's
why now the realm of normal politics
is so radically left-wing because we
haven't
fought back against that but what
political correctness does
fundamentally is it replaces traditional
moral codes
with new speech codes that's that's the
main shift that happens with political
correctness
and political correctness thereby
attempts to redefine reality
uh but it's an it's a purely negative
mission and what i mean by that is
the the radical left i don't think the
radical left particularly cares about
homosexuals and i don't think they
particularly care about people who are
confused about their sex
i think they are using these groups as a
means of destroying the old order so if
you can destroy the old order with one
argument use that if you can destroy the
old order
with the opposite argument you'll use
that but either way
what you're trying to do is destroy the
old set of standards
and it this is why uh
this is why the tactics have changed
over the years this this
a lot of it comes back to a line from
karl marx actually which is
uh that mark set out to to exert
the ruthless criticism of all that
exists
from that you get familiar terms like
critical theory right from these kind of
western marxists who later on came
and applied marx more to cultural
matters and kind of melded them with
freud and
anyway go you can go read the book to
understand a little tiny bit of this
um but it is it is purely
negative and it's going to accelerate
and you're already
seeing it accelerate in real time
all of these kind of radical picks from
the biden administration and it has
cultural effects too i just saw this
on this question of gender ideology one
of the silliest headlines i've seen in a
long time
in the new york post 23 year old topples
king with a gender neutral card deck
and it's this gal here you know and
she's got this new deck of cards and she
was very upset
that in a traditional deck of cards
when you're most games i guess when
you're playing the king
is more valuable than the queen we
cannot have this
this is very terrible right because
that's patriarchal or something
so this girl she got in she got a news
article out of this
in a major publication she just made a
deck of cards
and replaced jack queen king with bronze
silver gold who's the ace i don't know
that's what she did topples the king
now faith moore drew's daughter faith
made this very good point the other day
when this article came out which is
if you topple the king don't you topple
the queen
too when this gal made her new deck of
cards
seems like such a frivolous story but it
actually matters to the culture
because because we're mimicking this or
rather she is mimicking the culture
and she is mimicking the political
regime we're doing this on so many
issues when you get rid of
if you want to topple the king and you
think you're going to do that by getting
rid of
any sort of gendered cards you're also
toppling the queen there is no queen
in this gal's deck of cards
modern gender ideologues you'll notice
it went very quickly from
you just see the acceleration it went
very quickly from
boys can become girls and girls can
become boys to something called
non-binary or
gender queer or non-gendered or whatever
they're like 50
different versions of this not people
saying i'm one sex or the other but
saying there is no sex there's no such
thing as sex i'm neither
and what that does to use a popular term
from the left is
it erases women there are no women now
you might say well at least the women
aren't
ranked lower in the deck of cards than
the men okay fine
but if that's a victory it's a pyrrhic
victory because there are no women left
anymore
because the minute that you assert that
there are women that there's such a
thing as men and women
well if those are distinct categories
that means there are differences
they're going to be some things that men
are better at and they're going to be
some things that women are better at
i've been in the delivery ward of a
hospital for two days
i understand there are some things that
women are better at
i understand that very well there are
going to be some ways in which men are
stronger
they're going to be some ways in which
women are stronger there are going
it won't be identical
this was people would have laughed at
you
if you had made this point any time from
the beginning of civilization
even earlier than that to about five or
ten years ago
people would have laughed at you if you
if you made the statement
men and women are different as as though
it were some grand epiphany
now that is politically incorrect speech
and they're probably going to censor
people who try to say that sort of thing
that's the new normal we've been talking
about the new normal with the masks
and the lockdowns well that's part of it
but the new normal is much broader
much more radical than any of that sort
of thing
and all this on the day we have to say
farewell to the trumps
melania trump came out she gave a
farewell address first
it was very sad to see this i love
melania trump she is the most elegant
first lady we've ever had she makes
everyone's heart go pitter-patter
my wife will send me videos of melania's
speaking just saying
oh michael oh my gosh my heart's melting
you know she just walks out she's so
composed so beautiful she said something
that i i think it's it's worth
thinking about as we enter the biden
administration not because it's any
groundbreaking statement not because
it's even objectively true but because
it describes
the current political situation melania
trump says be passionate
in everything you do in the midst of
hardship
we have seen the best of america shine
through
students have made cards and delivered
groceries
to our senior citizens teachers
have worked twice as hard to keep our
children learning
families have come together to provide
meals
supplies comfort and friendship to those
in need
be passionate in everything you do but
always remember
that violence is never the answer
and will never be justified
okay objectively what she's saying is
not true
right even she says violence is never
the answer well violence
was the answer uh in war wasn't it when
when war is declared on us
certainly we would all say the answer to
that is violence not just to roll over
right was violence the answer in world
war
ii that seems to be the only historical
reference point that anybody has
everyone's always comparing everyone
else to the nazis or whatever
but okay let's use it was violence the
answer in world war ii
uh probably it was right you know if
someone is
some madman is trying to conquer the
whole world and violence is the answer
to that
it's never a justified note it is
justified uh st thomas aquinas and many
many other thinkers have discussed
when it is justified i think what
melania's saying here is that unjust
violence is not justified
you know sort of vigilantism or riots
everywhere or looting or whatever of
course
that's not justified that's not
justified at all and probably this is a
reference to the capital hill riot sure
it should also be a reference to blm
fair enough and then she says be
passionate in everything you do well
there's some places where you you know
a little detachment is fine too but i i
don't mean to nitpick the first lady's
speech because i think there's actually
some real wisdom in here
what we have had if nothing else for the
past four years
is passion it's why
an unusual coalition of voters came
together and sent trump to washington in
the first place
it's why people have had so much fun
over the last four years
is we had passion and it seemed like for
the first time
in my life we had passion from
the the white house obama in a way
you know had a little bit of passion but
obama was speeding things up in a little
bit of way but it was all still the same
kind of liberal establishment
and maybe clinton bill clinton advanced
that
a little more slowly and bush a little
more slowly and obama a little more
quickly it was all the same thing
it was all the exact same thing it's all
the same kind of platitudes and the same
kind of dull
bureaucratic technocratic language and
then trump comes in like a wrecking ball
and that really fired a lot of us up and
we thought that was oh there's actually
some hope
that we can avoid this kind of bizarre
insane
ugly anti-american technocratic malaise
and we got that with trump and now
trump's leaving
it's very sad trump giving his farewell
address
wishing joe biden well my fellow
americans
four years ago we launched a great
national effort
to rebuild our country to renew its
spirit
and to restore the allegiance of this
government to its citizens
in short we embarked on a mission to
make america great again for all
americans
as i conclude my term as the 45th
president of the united states i stand
before you
truly proud of what we have achieved
together
we did what we came here to do
and so much more this week we
inaugurate a new administration
and pray for its success in keeping
america safe
and prosperous we extend our best wishes
and we also want them to have luck a
very
important word so he's going out on a
sort of nice gracious note okay
biden's coming in we've accomplished all
we wanted to and much much more
there's some things obviously the trump
administration didn't accomplish but i
will say
without a doubt he's uh the favorite
president of my lifetime
and and he he talked about
the same sort of thing we've been
talking about all day that this doesn't
neatly
cut across into our politics the trumpet
the trump administration
was unique in our normal political
regime he says it's not about left or
right it's about doing good for the
american people
together with millions of hard-working
patriots across this land
we built the greatest political movement
in the history of our country
we also built the greatest economy in
the history of the world
it was about america first because we
all wanted to
make america great again we restored the
principle that a nation exists
to serve as citizens our agenda was not
about
right or left it wasn't about republican
or democrat
but about the good of a nation and that
means
the whole nation with the support and
prayers of the american people
we achieved more than anyone thought
possible
nobody thought we could even come close
you know i usually don't like this
rhetoric of it's not about left it's not
about right
it's not red america blue america right
obama's said similar things
but the reason i don't love that even
the country over party or whatever these
other slogans is because
you join a political party to help your
country the idea is this party is going
to help the country more so i'm going to
join that and support it so i think it's
a little bit of a false dichotomy and
the trump administration's been
generally very right-wing with some
exceptions
but it is worth pointing out he was a
little different he wasn't the usual
republican
he cracked that status quo
for a little bit in part of cracking it
was he won he got a lot of things
accomplished at least the first time
then we had a pretty strange 2020 pretty
strange november of 2020
and that's that's the end of the term
farewell to
the best president of my lifetime i hope
president trump stays
around as a voice in politics very sorry
to see joe biden inaugurated today
but hey thank thanks for the memories
and we've got a lot to look forward to i
got a new kid
we got things to be happy about i will
look forward to seeing you all tomorrow
in the meantime i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knowles show
see you then
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show